hey david uh i'm in i'm from australia
and i'm trying to figure out why so many
americans do not vote
isn't it obvious that it is just the
fundamental basic participation
in your democracy and that it is the
starting point for all political
involvement
yes uh yes i you know for me i have said
many times i don't believe in this stuff
of if you don't vote you don't get to
complain
that seems kind of silly and and
reductive uh
but i do think that anybody
who cares at all about the country they
live in
should as a minimum be voting in
addition to whatever else they are doing
now the question of why more people
don't vote is a good question it's easy
to say well more people don't vote
because it's not mandatory
that's not what what i think is really
the interesting part the more
interesting part to me is
what are the reasons that people choose
not to vote
and there's a very interesting study of
non-voters
and you can find this on the 538 website
and it looked at why voters versus
non-voters
uh end up not voting rather it compared
the reasons that people who never vote
don't vote
versus the reasons that people who
sometimes vote
don't end up voting one of the reasons
that non-voters choose never to vote is
they believe that it doesn't matter who
wins
nothing will change for people like them
and unfortunately this is one of those
kind of fallacious beliefs you know we
hear this idea that sometimes people
will say
elections really never come down to one
vote
so therefore my vote doesn't matter so
i'm going to stay home and while it's
true that elections
rarely come down to one vote
particularly national elections
um if everybody who had that thought
occurred to them
stayed home or voted then you actually
would
be able to change the outcomes and maybe
influence
what your day-to-day life is like so
that that's a really unfortunate one
one of the reasons it feels like things
don't change is so many people aren't
voting if everybody was voting things
would actually change
another reason that non-voters often
don't vote
is they believe the system is too broken
to be fixed by voting that's sort of a
version of the same thing
and then um some folks who believe that
because of where they live
their vote doesn't matter which is a
direct um
critique of the electoral college and
then lastly
one of the reasons that a lot of
non-voters cite for not voting is
they're not sure
if they can vote which is really just
depressing
um there are situations in which you
would not be allowed to vote
because of a criminal conviction and we
know that that's being dealt with at the
state level in a variety of different
states
but um other than not knowing if you are
registered or knowing when you can
register i mean
the idea that people don't vote because
they're not sure if they can vote that's
a failure of the system for sure
and then you have to look at which party
has an interest in reducing voter
turnout and of course we know that it's
been the republican party
we know that the republican party has
covertly
been working on reducing turnout for
decades and
overtly doing it for at least 10 or 12
years uh check out the mike turzai video
back in 2012
i believe it is where he openly says
voter id
is going to deliver pennsylvania to mitt
romney so
that's just a depressing reality now we
could solve a lot of these problems
if we eliminate this idea of voter
registration if it's simply
you turn 18 and you're a citizen you can
vote you don't need to register
that resolves a lot of the issue as to
whether one is allowed to vote that
should be done
um if we uh uh deal with this issue
of have i been purged or do i need id or
not
all of these things they when we talk
about voter there's a reason it's called
voter suppression
it really does suppress the vote um and
then of course people feeling like the
system is broken i mean to some degree i
sympathize with them
and at the same time i recognize that
the the lower
participation is in elections the more
broken it's going to be the more the
system will be representative
of those who choose to vote so the
voting
voting is is just the starting point i
get that voting isn't
everything but it is depressing when i
see you know 52
turnout uh fortunately we were over 60
this november but this is a real problem
in the united states i don't
know that you really solve it in a deep
way
simply by making voting mandatory my
birth country of argentina has mandatory
voting
i don't know that it in itself gives us
less corrupt
outcomes but that's a bigger issue and
probably one for a different day
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com